you ever seen those big round bales okay
we got some hay so we're going to play
and wonder just how much hay is really
squished in there I mean compared to
like a square bail it's little but these
big round bales is it all loose is it
really tight is it super heavy well
we're going to rip one apart here and
see if it's enough to bury a person
in yeah bury a person you know kind of
like at the beach oh you bury person in
sand well we bought three round bales
here and let's go ahead and rip them
apart see how many it's going to take to
make a pile that we can get a person
buried in all right so let's see if we
can push it here first we thought we're
going to have to rip it apart where it's
at and haul it but nope here we go
rolling like a Snowman
cross the field pushing it to Nowhere
middle of nowhere pushing pushing
pushing we're heading out to middle of
the swamp
here still
going hey Bale it's really really heavy
I don't know how much this thing weighs
way too much to lift that's for
sure all right we're pretty much where
we're going to rip this thing apart here
so
let's get
these bail twine string things off of
here snapping them ripping them to the
side they're packed in there pretty
good and the fun begins here we go
ripping them
apart starting to make a pile going to
take a long time to get pile to Bear
someone in right
there lot of that roll left though
oh yeah it's getting there pile's
getting bigger let getting
there that's really
dusty very H
Dusty lot of work this is getting
exhausting W that's nice
that was a pretty lean jump
there it's a lot of hay one round bail
that's a lot of fun in one round bail
uhhuh hey that's why we want
this looks like one bail is all it needs
one bail and we got a huge pile of hay
here there you go now you
know makes nonsense